دعني ابدا معك من العنف الذي نراه يتجدد
في الشرق الاوسط باعمال عنف بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين وايضا حزب الله
هل كان هذا متوقعا
لا اعتقد بان العنف
كان مفاجئا لاي من المراقبين للشرق الاوسط
فسبقه وان كانت هناك منذ اشهر
الزياده فيها العنف بين اسرائيل
والفلسطيني 2022 كانت اكثر السنوات عنفا
منذ حوالي عاقدين
بعدد القتلى بين الفلسطينيين على ايدي
القوات الاسرائيليه وكذلك الاسرائيليين
على ايديا الفلسطينيين وعلاوه على ذلك
لدينا
في شاري ديسمبر من العمل الماضي اكثر
وحكومه متطرف جناحها اليمين يتولد السلطه
في تاريخ اسرائيل
بل كذلك كل المخاوف التي بثتها على الجانب
الفلسطيني
هناك حاله جمود في الوضع القائم على في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بين فلسطين واسرائيل
هذا كله يؤدي الى تجدد العنف بسبب او بدون
سبب مهما كان السبب صغير الا يوجد هناك
اليه ماليه لتحريك اي اي شيء في سماء هذه
المنطقه من اجل تغيير هذا الوضع طالما ان
العنف متجدد ومتكرر
عندما كنا نتحدث عن
النزاع الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني فنعم
لا توجد اي نتيجه لذلك فما يخص اي حل
لهذا النزاع وعلينا ان نبحث اولا واخرا عن
الوضع الاسرائيلي
واغلب الاسرائيليين بامكانهم ان يعيشوا
فيه حياه طبيعيه
وينسون
خلالهما يجري في الجانب الاخر في جدار
الفاصل مع الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربي
وكذلك في قطاع غزه والى ان يكون هنالك
تغيير اساسي في رغبه الجانب الاسرائيلي
فلا اتوقع اننا سنشهد اي تقدم خاصه وان
الطرف الاساسي الرئيسي الخارجي هو
الولايات المتحده لم تتناء عن سياساتها
الاساسيه لرؤيه نفسه على انها دعم الاكبر
لاسرائيل